[inaudible] like a dream.
Let's get your chute up.
I'm ready.
Here we go.
BEAR GRYLLS: Terry Crews and I
just landed on a small airfield
in the Icelandic mountains.
Last night, he told
me that skydiving
was on his bucket list.
Well, Terry, be careful
what you wish for.
I'm very nervous.
It feel really real, wow.
You're going to be like this.
I'm going to fly around
this side of you, yeah.
A nice, bug, banana.
We're going to be here.
We're hooked up with one of our
team who is a tandem master.
We've got two chutes.
I got to ask, is
unconsciousness a thing?
For sure.
What would knock
you unconscious?
Jumping out of a plane
door open while it's
flying it 150 miles an hour.
Yeah, it's like [inaudible].
Something cut you, you
hit your head on something,
or we crash into each other.
We're falling at
150 mile an hour.
Yeah.
We're going to hook him
up, get him out his plane,
and take him to
12,000 feet, door
open, and then throw him out.
Quick final checks.
[inaudible] good.
Feeling good inside.
You're going to see
the look of terror.
I believe my mother is
watching over me at all times.
Trust the process.
Trust yourself.
OK.
She was always
proud of me, and I
always want to make her proud.
And today, I plan to
do that right now.
We're all here.
That's it.
- No going back.
When that door closes--
No going back.
I'm going up there to be
a little closer to my mom.
Whoo.
Oh, we're up here.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
BEAR GRYLLS: Look
at these clouds.
This is going to be epic.
Where we at now?
BEAR GRYLLS: Not even five yet.
We got to get to 12.
PILOT: Approaching
the jump site now.
Maintaining 12,000 feet.
Jumpers, get ready.
Here we go.
PILOT: Open the door, guys.
You ready?
BEAR GRYLLS: Here we go.
There's no going back now.
Let's go.
Whoo.
PILOT: You guys are good to go.
- Here we go.
Oh, my God.
Ready, [inaudible].
Oh.
Yeah, whoa.
I love it, whoo.
[inaudible], Terry.
We got him.
He's on the canopy.
TERRY CREWS: I am doing it.
I am flying right now.
Absolutely incredible.
Thank you, Bear.
Thank you.
This whole experience, man, I
mean literally, sleeping next
to a volcano, hanging off
the side of helicopters, man,
jumping out of planes.
[inaudible] what can I say, man?
This is crazy.